okay listen so Fox News has reported on
Roseanne bars response to me on Twitter
yesterday after her firing but has
removed all evidence that she was
actually responding to me so remind you
yesterday when Roseanne said that ambien
may have been responsible we can
actually go back to the beginning this
all started when Roseanne tweeted Muslim
Brotherhood and Planet of the Apes had a
baby equals Valerie Jarrett that got her
fired from ABC News and then she put out
there the idea that it was ambien that
was in some way responsible for these
tweets and when she did that I responded
to her and said on Twitter oh man this
is just the best Roseanne is now
defending her tweets by saying ambien
made her racist and she responded
directly to me saying no I didn't I
blamed myself
stop lying yes I have had odd ambien
experiences on tweeting late at night
like many other people do I blame myself
okay it's just an explanation not an
excuse okay bully so Fox News reported
on that tweet they removed the reference
to her tweeting to Deep hackman which is
me and they also removed that last thing
where she said okay bully because that
would make it sort of obvious that she's
responding to someone and here is how
Fox News reported on Roseanne Bars tweet
to me no evidence that I was involved in
this thing whatsoever
Roseanne then simultaneously thanked her
supporters for defending her and then
asked them not to stick up for her
quoting hey guys don't defend me it's
sweet of you to try but losing my show
is zero compared to being labeled a
racist over one tweet that I regret even
more and then when she blamed ambien man
Twitter took her to task on Roseanne
responded quoting no I didn't I blamed
myself
stop lying yes I have had odd ambien
experiences on tweeting late at night
like many other people do I blame myself
okay and the ellipses there which was
visible to people who are watching tells
the tale of what was removed which was
calling me a bully I don't
we care but it's yet again I mean just a
month or so ago when Stephen Colbert
picked up on the fact that Melania had
liked our tweet or a tweet about our
story questioning what's going on with
her and Donald Trump's relationship
Stephen Colbert also removing all
references to me and I know it's not all
about me but it's just funny that we
keep getting cooked by corporate media I
think they just don't want to get lost
in the details so it's not a direct
insult it's more of a missed opportunity
I think I think it's a missed
opportunity is the right way to say it I
like how your Twitter though and in your
Twitter who took her to task right I
heard the Twitter took her to task and
they showed a response it was a response
to me right it would have been nice to
get a little mention but that sounded
like trace Gallagher reading those
tweets not expecting a shout-out from
trace Gallagher anytime soon on Fox News
the video you just watched was made
possible by support from you please go
to patreon.com slash david pakman show
you can make a pledge of as little as
one dollar per month and every dollar
helps to support the work that we're
doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad